Sure your mobile phone will give you the
time, but not nearly as conveniently or
fashionably as a wristwatch does.
Watches come in a variety of materials,
often combined with stainless steel, but one
of the more creative pairings is stainless
steel with wood.
This company makes wristwatches, which
feature exotic hardwood accents.
This particular model is a limited edition
series designed for New York Yankees baseball
fans. The blue painted maple comes from
wooden seats salvaged from the original
Yankee Stadium, which opened in 1923.
At the watch factory, a worker first cuts a
strip of wood just over a third of an inch
thick, then cuts it into blocks, measuring
around three fourths of an inch by a third of
an inch each. Manufacturers will ultimately
use these blocks to make the wood inlays and
the links of the watch bracelet.
The worker then cuts another strip from a
piece of wood, this one nearly a quarter of
an inch thick. The worker then cuts this
strip into nearly two by two inch squares.
Each one will become a ring called a bezel
that goes around the watch dial.
Another worker mounts one square at a time
on a lathe and bores a hole through the
middle. She mounts several board squares
onto a steel mandrel that attaches to the
lathe along with a bezel template.
As the lathe turns a steel roughing gouge,
rounds the squares to the diameter of the
template. She takes one bezel at a time and
cuts it to the required thickness about a
10th of an inch.
She then shaves wood from the underside so as
not to remove the historic blue paint on top.
To make the watch case which houses the dial
and movement.
The manufacturers cut a blank piece of
extruded stainless steel.
Then place it in a computer guided machine.
Under a continuous shower of lubricant.
The machine's 12 different tools take turns
shaping the piece into a watch case.
The first tools bore a hole in the middle
for the movement and carve a groove around
the hole for the wood bezel.
The next tools cut the outside profile of
the case and the lugs for attaching the watch
band. Then the final tool drills holes in
the lugs for the spring loaded pins that
attach the watch band to the case.
Another computer guided machine makes the
watchband and links out of a bar of stainless
steel. This machine reduces the bar in
width, carves out the links and bores holes
for the connecting pins.
A process called.
Iron plating puts a black finish on all the
stainless steel parts.
Then a worker assembles two bands and
connects one to the watch clasp.
Next, he attaches the watch case window.
It's made of sapphire glass, a crystal
that's exceptionally durable.
He inserts the Self-winding movement in
dial.
The dial is a sheet of brass with cut out
numbers and indices over a base coated in
luminescent paint.
The watch glows in the dark.
He secures the movement to the case with the
retaining ring, then inserts the crown, which
sets the dials hands.
The worker screws on the stainless steel
case back.
The watch's window of sapphire glass allows
you to see the working movement inside.
The Caseback is engraved with the name of
the limited edition collection, and this
watch is number in the series.
He attaches the watchband to the case with
spring pins.
With the watch now fully assembled, it's
time to inlay the Yankee Stadium wooden chair
accents. Using a toothpick.
A worker applies epoxy glue to the
rectangular recess in each link.
Then he places a wooden link piece in each
recess.
He follows the same process for the dials.
Wooden bezel. A worker sets the watch aside
for 24 hours to let the adhesive set.
Then the worker buffs the entire surface on
a cloth polishing wheel.
This process removes the fingerprints and
dust and smooths those historic wood accents.
The watch automatically winds with wrist
movement to reliably tell the time while
nostalgically going back in time.
Before the invention of electricity,
criminal acts were hidden by darkness.
Police officers carried special lanterns as
they pursued suspects.
Today, craftsmen replicate these lanterns
for the movie and television industries.
These props are authentically replicated
pieces of police history with a thick bull's
eye lens to magnify the light from the
flame.
The 19th century police lantern helped find
bad guys on shadowy streets.
To replicate a vintage police lantern, the
craftsman starts with a piece of steel using
a scribe. He traces around a pattern to
transfer the outline to the blank.
He marks notches for hinges and for the
latch and etches the shape of the lens hole
in the center. He draws two diagonal lines
in the lens hole area.
The point where the lines intersect
determines the exact center.
He punches a divot into the steel at this
cross point.
He scribes lines along the edges for bending
into a reinforced border.
Later on, he cuts out the hinge and latch
notches.
Following the transferred pattern lines.
Next, he aligns the center divot with a
punch and then activates the punch to cut out
the hole for the lantern lens.
The craftsman now bends wire to match the
profile of the lantern door.
He aligns the wire with the scribed lines on
the edge of the door and folds the metal over
it. Bending the door to the correct
curvature completes the part.
Following another pattern.
The craftsman marks the location for vent
holes in the blank that will become the
Lantern's main structure.
He cuts out the vent holes where he's made
the marks using a hand-operated punch.
He then rolls the blank into a cylinder.
It takes a couple of passes to achieve the
correct curvature.
Moving on to the lantern's lens holder, the
craftsman crimps a bead around one end.
This bead helps to retain the bull's eye
lens in the holder.
Returning to the lantern body, he hammers the
top rim around the cap.
He preps the surface for soldering with a
chemical cleaning agent known as flux.
He then solders the joint to secure the top
to the lantern.
He also solders a raised panel to the back.
This substantial panel serves as support for
handles.
He then cleans the solder joints with
acetone.
Next, he wraps metal hinges around the wire
that runs through the notches in the door.
He crimps the hinges together at the ends
and positions the door on the lantern body.
He adjusts the hinges so the ends at level
on the lantern.
He solders the hinges to the steel
structure.
The craftsman inserts the bull's eye lens
assembly into the hole in the center of the
lantern door, and he solders the joint he
pins and solders the two tears of a copper
chimney. He places the chimney over the hole
in the top of the lantern and tucks more pins
into holes in the chimney.
The craftsman installs a decorative part in
the top one that won't obstruct the chimney
hole. He assembles the handles to the raised
panel at the back of the lantern.
Once the soldered seam hardens, he files it
down, the craftsman test the latch on the
door and confirms that it operates
perfectly.
After taping up the lens and handles, he
spray paints the lantern black.